foreign
what's up Shay
hey how are you doing we are partying
what are you up to that's not true I'm
not I'm not I'm just at work what are
you doing
oh
just living a dream
anytime somebody says they're living the
dream they are for sure not living the
dream what's going on
I I've had Adrian not the dream
excellent good good work right there all
right so what's up
I am
really struggling with motherhood and
specifically
getting over stimulated and overwhelmed
with my kids and all the
responsibilities that come with it and
I'm just looking for
any help any way that I can work through
that I love my kids of course with
everything for the rest of the show you
don't even have to repeat that because I
know that I know you love them
okay
um over stimulation with moms is kind of
a Hot Topic right now tell me tell me
what that means to you
do you have kids I do right you know
I'm sure anyone who's seen a small child
in a busy area
you get overwhelmed by the sights and
the sounds and the noises and they get
cranky and they start fussing and having
issues I feel like that as an adult
I
have a hard time with the noises one of
my kids constantly moves never stops
running never stops climbing fidgeting
the other one cannot stop talking
he talks a mile a minute he is probably
a hundred thousand words a day
constantly
and so between the sounds and the
movement and
then do you walk through do you walk
through your kitchen and you feel little
things under your feet
oh constantly and then you step on your
truck or a Lego and there's a crumb then
a thing and it's all it's like sensory
overload
it is all the time and I don't want to
be overloaded with my kids and with
motherhood of course
I I get
I either get to the point where I'm so
hyper focused on everything that's going
on or I completely shut down
and my kids deserve better than that
I wouldn't say better these are
different
okay
is that cool
yeah okay
um so what's the
what's the core message
that you feel in your chest like a
ticker tape at the bottom of like a Fox
News or CNN or something like that
what is the core message
of a mom with two Wily little kids
like when you have a kid that won't stop
talking you have a kid that's just kind
of running around everywhere and
tripping and falling and there's crumbs
and there's rappers and there's what is
that core message in your chest what are
you what are you telling yourself
I guess that I'm failing there it is
and what's beneath I'm failing
what's the message beneath that one
it's probably the one you've been
sitting on since you were a little bitty
girl
I'm not good enough yeah worthless
I'm freaking worthless and here's guest
exhibit number
144.
I can't even keep my kids fill in the
blank and then that's followed by
what kind of mom doesn't even like her
own kids
Fair
yeah
and then your sweet body
spins up trying to take care of you and
it runs as fast as it can until it
collapses then it spins back up and runs
as fast as it can until it collapses
are you married
I am then knucklehead comes home and
starts pawing at you and you're like
God if you touch me I'm gonna kill you
and you kind of like some conversation
but you kind of like sleeping with them
and then you think what kind of ma wife
am I that won't even sleep with this
great what's the Met right
yeah absolutely touched out is the word
we use in my household yep what's the
word
etched out touchdown touchdown
so instead of that touch being a safe
place like a like a place that you can't
wait to get to it's a place that makes
you feel like you're electrified
so I want you to think of your body as
doing its best job to protect you
and it's been protecting you from this
core message that you're you're not
worth much or anything
for a long long time
I talk to people all over the country
that get that mess got that message from
their Church growing up
that you were such a worthless
disgusting creature
that God had to murder his kid so that
your disgustingness could right that was
part of the narrative or it could have
been from Dad could have been from Mom
Are you seriously going to wear that it
would have killed you to get one more a
really
oh my gosh gross eat that he never
stopped
and this core message is you're not good
enough you're not good enough you're not
good enough
and then and then marriage is going to
rescue us right we're going to find that
guy who loves us do you feel safe with
him
so I'm gonna ask you something weird a
common threat and it's not always so
tell me I'm wrong I'm wrong
but a common response to the message of
I'm worthless
when you find somebody that you feel
safe with your body actually kind of
slows down a little bit with
you overdo it with them to the point
that they're like ah you're a lot and
they say it in their nice kind way
because that's usually those kind of
people
and you feel it when they go ah and then
they try to
re-jump the bridge through sex am I onto
something
I think that sounds real familiar
actually your husband called me and like
filled me in on everything and you're
I'm just kidding not even a little bit
no not that wouldn't surprise me it's
okay so here's here's the goal here
the goal is not to be less over
stimulated
I know that sounds bananas
overstimulation is your body trying to
get your attention Okay we don't protect
our houses from burning down by taking
all the smoke detectors out
what we want to do is address that core
message
that yet again you're not worth anything
and it's not true
that's that's the that's the problem
with it is it's not true it's a lie it's
false
and so we are going to begin a practice
where when our body starts taking off on
us
we're going to catch it we're going to
have somebody that we trust that could
be your husband that could be your
girlfriend of yours that could be
um
um your mom if she's safe she probably
is not based on your story
um it could be a a counselor whatever
but all we're going to do is when we
feel our body when one kid's running
around and you say stop running and they
just keep running and instantly that's
it right there your body dumps into your
own kid won't even listen to you
yeah wait a way to be nice mom
and then you yell or snap and then
you're like ah and you're a terrible mom
too
we're just gonna stop right there and
we're literally gonna put our hand on
our chest and we're gonna feel our
bodies
and we're going to Exhale really deep
and say
that's not true
I'm not a terrible mom
I'm exhausted
Tada I get to be exhausted not terrible
I am not worthless and we're going to be
really intentional about I am statements
I am a good wife
and I am a great mom
and I am working to practice on some new
things that I've never done before in my
life
do you hear how one of these is so much
more peaceful than going to war
so
here's a couple of weird things I want
you to practice okay
okay and you're not going to find this
in traditional parent literature
um in there so they're kind of weird
number one I want you to practice
not using your kids as a report card
okay here's what that means when your
kid does something ridiculous like
knocks over a plate of chips in a
restaurant or yells real loud I don't
want you to look around and make eye
contact with other people
I want you to feel your body kind of
getting embarrassed and ashamed and oh
my gosh and then go he's two you know
what two-year-olds do knock over chip
bowls
next time I as the adult I'm just gonna
remember to move the chips
ta-da no war no fight no running no body
starting to try to defend me because
there's nothing to defend I'm just gonna
remember to move the chips next time
when somebody says man this one's got a
lot of energy
let your first impulse I want you to
practice this be thank God
it's so great
it's a lot but it's so great
do you see what I'm saying we're
practicing new ways of doing that okay
and you're gonna stumble and fall and
trip and screw up and be like oh gosh
he's the worst then you're gonna catch
yourself be like he can be the worst
but man I'm glad these health and he's
running around and we're just gonna
practice that okay here's the second one
and when I say this I don't want you
just to immediately run into a big ball
of burning shame okay it sounds like an
old uh My Chemical Romance song but I
don't want you to be like just a ball of
Shame
okay okay
I want you to practice
being likable
and here's what I mean by being likable
not being a doormat not having feelings
that's not what I mean
whenever you find yourself about to tell
your kid to stop running around I want
you to ask yourself why
why am I deciding that this is an
important Hill is he unsafe then yeah of
course
and instead of yelling I'm just gonna
get up and pick him up
or
I have this picture that a perfect mom
has perfect kids and perfect kids don't
move they don't run around they don't
ask questions they don't talk too much
and that's not true
perfect kids are
silly and rambunctious and quiet and
loud and some sleep and some aren't very
good at sleeping it's a it's just a
bunch of different pictures
and so
when I say practice being likable
practice skipping every other
hey stop hey quick quick hey quit asked
can you just put skip every one of those
or when one of your kids starts talking
I want you to like you can put your hand
up and go or put your hand on them and
say hey mom needs seven minutes
when this clock says one four two
I want to hear all about your story
and you are going to have three minutes
I want you to tell me the whole story
are you ready and they'll go yeah
and then you take those seven minutes
and you breathe and you go and you go ah
and some of that chatter will have
dissipated and there will be a core
story there that you can hold your kids
hands squat down and look them in the
eye and say tell me all about it
and now your body's not trying to do 48
things at once it's just lasered in here
and you're gonna find that that kid
isn't as knowing as you think it is
think he or she is
and all we're doing we're just
practicing being likable
and with your husband there's a way that
you can push and push and push until you
snap we're just gonna go way Upstream
and you're gonna he's gonna ask you
every morning what's the best way I can
love you today
and what you're going to find in a
couple of weeks or a couple of months is
man if you do bedtimes or help with
bedtimes and if you just see a dish in
the sink I have a strange thing about
dishes in the sink or whatever the thing
is for you
um
you are going to have more peace and
he's gonna have a lot more sex than you
are too obviously see what I'm saying
yes okay so I threw a lot at you I want
to hear back from you
you may have you may be like dude John
I've done all of these things or this
may be totally new tell me what your
feeling as I'm talking
a big conversation actually okay
um my product of listening to your show
all the time
okay tell me how that conversation went
it's
did not start off as a calm conversation
but we
the more we talk about
our individual needs not being that we
figured out that
if our needs aren't being met we don't
want to meet the other ones mean there
you go and so we are both trying to make
a more concerted efforts
and helping the other one get what they
want and what they need
that is helpful that is beautiful here's
my here's my mechanics question how did
y'all set that up did you tell him a
list of needs that you have and he told
you a list
yes okay I want to change that a little
bit okay
okay needs are very Dynamic what I mean
by Dynamic is they're different all the
time they're always moving
so I want you to come up with a regular
morning practice where you ask each
other how can I help meet your needs
today how can I love you best today
because some days you're going to be
like I want to do the dishes and not
look at another human or talk
and he may walk in and do all the dishes
he's like I do all the dishes so you can
have more time with the kids and you're
like I'm gonna go bury myself in the
backyard
right so I want this needs conversation
to be something y'all do every single
day
and what you're going to find is just
the intimacy of this conversation
is going to be extraordinary
and you're gonna find that some days you
have this need some days you have that
need some days he has this needs some
days you have that need
you might just have a picture of he
needs more sex okay so you're just gonna
have a picture of sex a picture of sex
well he may want rambunctious
silly we just got like
can't wait to get home sex and then
other days he may want to just
sit with you and have old like
connection boring married sex like what
it's gonna be different every time and
so I want y'all to make this a practice
is that fair
yeah absolutely all right I want you to
say out loud
I'm worthy of being a wife and I'm
worthy of being a mom
I'm worthy of being a mom
and I want you to say out loud I am not
worthless
I am not worthless
that story is not true
say it
is that hard to say
there it is yeah
so when you get up the courage to call a
counselor that's going to be where we
start
my core story
my core message
that I tell myself on a regular bit it's
encoded into my DNA is that I'm
worthless
and I've tried to achieve academically
and I've tried to achieve I've fallen
the rules or I've tried to get people's
attentions by drinking a lot or I've
tried to marry the perfect guy and had
the perfect kids
and the underlying ticker tape story is
over and over and over again
you are worthless what are you doing
here just go just leave in that story is
a lie
the roots of that story that we feel
we begin to think through new things and
then we begin to practice new ways of
doing life
and hey let's be honest if you get a
house cleaner
tell your husband to vacuum that may
help too